GOOD MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE PRECAUTIONS THE MANAGER ON
GOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BURKE DISSIPATION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE EVEREST THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 THAT IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO
OBVIOUSLY ON MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE- STREET BUILDING
AND OBVIOUSLY I ASKED ALL THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT HERE TO
COME ON DOWN SO WE CAN GET GOING
WE HAVE SEVENTY ONE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA ALL OF THE
MEASURES ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS INFORMED US THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE FILES FOR ANY
OF THE BILLS WE ARE HEARING. AND
THE REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING TODAY FOR ANYONE
LISTENING WHO IS INTERESTED IN
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE-
TRELLEBORGS OR SB TWELVE
THIRTEEN HUESO THESE BILLS HAVE
BEEN SENT DIRECTLY TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT SO IF
YOU'RE HERE FOR FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE. AND TWELVE THIRTEEN.
THEY'RE ALREADY ON THE FOR.
BEFORE WE TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE
BILLS WERE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO MISTER CONSULTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES. BATES HERE
SENATOR BRADFORD CENTER JONES
CENTER KAMLAGER. SENATE EARLIER
HERE CENTER LAYERED HERE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE E. HERE ACOSTA HERE
WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS PRESENT. WE
HAVE FOUR MEMBERS WHICH IS A
QUORUM SHOW DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. I RESERVE THE RIGHT
TO INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESSES EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL
TIME FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY. SO
IF THERE'S TWO OF YOU THAT'S ONE
AND A HALF MINUTES EACH. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. IF NECESSARY WILL
ALSO INSTITUTE AN ADDITIONAL.
TIME LIMIT FOR TWELVE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE OF AN ISSUE IF WE
NEED TO. AS A REMINDER CALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RE LITIGATE THE POLICY
MERITS. WE'RE ONLY GONNA TALK
ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACTS. SO
PLEASE HOLD TO YOUR ME TOO-
COMMENTS AS APPROPRIATE. AND
WE'RE GONNA JUMP RIGHT INTO SB
EIGHT THIRTY WHICH I KNOW THE
AUTHOR QUITE WELL. SB. EIGHT
THIRTY PORTANTINO ON EDUCATION
FINANCE. AN SUPPLE ED. FUND IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I HAVE WAY
PRESENT. AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WISHING ANYBODY
WISHING TO SUPPORT. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM JUMPING TO
THE MICROPHONE. TO SUPPORT SB
EIGHT THIRTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THIRTY. AND
IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO
TO SUPPORT. CAN GO FIRST THE
LINE NUMBER. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER MEMBERS ALL YOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOUR IS
SITTING QUE SHERIFF'S IS GOING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ZERO. AND
NOT AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY AND WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED EIGHT THIRTY SEEING
NO ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
THIRTY. TO OPPOSE NOW PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
CURRENTLY. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AS NOTED
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
OFFERING TESTIMONY TODAY SO
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT THIRTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE LIVING ON SB NINE
FIFTY NINE ALSO BY PORTANTINO ON
SURPLUS RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY IN
THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE NINE.
AND IT IS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY NINE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED MODERATES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB NINE FIVE NINE. AND
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO.
CURRENTLY NONE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND WE
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR LEARN
HOW WE DON'T HAVE A QUESTION I
WAS JUST GOING TO SUGGEST THAT
THE CHAIR SCRUTINIZED THIS BILL
IN THE PREVIOUS ONE VERY
CLOSELY. I SHALL DO THAT ITH
YOUR SUGGESTION YOU CAN BE A CO
AUTHOR TO A FEW MORE. OUR RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER- COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE FIVE
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. MOVING ON SB EIGHT
EIGHT TWO BY SENATOR EGGMAN-
ADVISORY COUNCIL IMPROVING
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE MS EGGMAN IS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION WE WILL GO RIGHT
TO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. MODDERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SBEIGHT EIGHT TWO.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO SUPPORT PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT EIGHT TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM MODERATE ORANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED EIGHT
EIGHT TWO. TO POST AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I AND
CURRENTLY NONE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION. I SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT EIGHT
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB NINE EIGHT THREE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN ON CONSUMER
WARRANTY PROTECTIONS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORTING SB NINE EIGHT
THREE. JUST PART SB NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINE. ALL RIGHT
WHAT OPPOSITION OF SB NINE EIGHT
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO THE MODERATORSOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB NINE EIGHT THREE.
KEPOS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINETY THREE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE SB TWELVE OH NINE
ALSO BY SENATOR EGGMAN IS ON
SENTENCING MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WITH THE RIGHT OF
THE TESTIMONY SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORTING SB TWELVE OH NINE.
AND TO SUPPORT AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NONE
ALL RIGHT WE GOT OPPOSITION IS
OR ANYONE OPPOSED S. B. TWELVE
OH NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TWELVE OH
NINE. INTERPOSE SB TWELVE OH
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE OR NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB EIGHT NINE
FOUR BY SENATOR JONES ON OFF
WHAT HIGHWAY VEHICLES. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE'RE GONNA
OP WILL GO TO SUPPORT POSITIONS
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT NINE FOUR. SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO EIGHT NINE FOR
MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT'S SUPPOSED. THE POST
AGAIN HIGHER. ONE THEN. ZERO
ANALYSTS FIFTY NINE ALL RIGHT
WITH TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ON S. B. EIGHT NINE
FOUR SEEING NO OBJECTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB EIGHT NINE FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB NINE SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR JONES ON HEALING
ARTS ALSO SUSPENSE. CANDIDATE
AND WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE EVERYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
SIX TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY NONE. ALL RIGHT WE GOT
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE SIX TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO NINE SIX TWO. AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND NINE CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT
WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF NINE SIXTY TWO SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE SIXTY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPEND MOVING ON
SB NINE OH FIVE BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON DECARBONISE CEMENT
AND GEOLOGIC CARBON
SEQUESTRATION DEMONSTRATION ACT
THIS IS THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
AND WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICH MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HALF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR SEEING
NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR MORE SUPPORT. OF SB NINE OH
FIVE. YOU TO SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS. ZERO CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WOULD OPPOSITION OF
NINE OH FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO SP NINE OH
FIVE MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE OH
FIVE. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT HERE. I GO TO A LINE NINETEEN IF I
HAD. THE NAME IS LAURA
ROSENBERGER HIRED LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. FRESNO THANK
YOU. IN ONE WOMAN HERE HAVE ONE
MORE TO SUPPORT. YOUR LINE.
TWENTY NINE. TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I CAN HEAR ME.
YEAH WE GOT. EXACTLY- THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A POSSIBLE
AND FISHING THANK YOU. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS BANK. BROWN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE ON
SUPPORT- BUT WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE OPPOSE
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ELSE OPPOSED
SB NINE OH FIVE. AND ONE ZERO SO
THERE'S NO RECOVERY. SENATE
ANYWAY. EIGHT ONE. CURRENTLY
MANY KIDS ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
OPPOSITION AND SEE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE OH
FIVE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB NINE THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
LEYVA. FUNDED TEARING. THE
DETERRING UNION MEMBERSHIP
VIOLATIONS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT MIKE
MULLIGAN WE HAVE THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR LEYVA
. AND TO SUPPORT SB NINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
DIRECTED BY. AND WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LOUIS GOSSETT WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATIVE
BOARD OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
RAIL AND TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. KNECHTEL LINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ALEXANDER WHO THEN REFERRED TO A
NEPHEW CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO NINE THIRTY
ONE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SP NINE
THIRTY ONE. TO OPPOSE SB NINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
VERIFY R. YEAH HE FIRED ME ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT. YEP A COUPLE HERE JUST A
MOMENT HERE. YOUR LINE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHAEL THE DARK ON
BEHALF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THE POST SB NINE
THIRTY ONE AND ESTIMATE COSTS IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF ONE AND A
HALF TO TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THANK YOU. THE
SIGNAL LINE. TWENTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE AARON HE AGREED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. AND
THEN FURTHER INTO IT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKING
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF NINE
THIRTY ONE AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION IT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB NINE FIVE FIVE BY SENATOR
LEYVA ON SIMPLE ATTENDANCE
EXCUSED ABSENCES THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTED SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
NINE FIVE FIVE. SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
NINE FIVE FIVE MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB NINE FIFTY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO SO. CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE FIVE FIVE AND
SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FIVE FIVE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB NINE
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR RUBIO IN
CALIFORNIA CHILDHOOD CANCER
RESEARCH THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE CENTERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MINORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THIRTY FOUR.
TO SUPPORT SB NINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
FOR MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE
THIRTY FOUR. AND TO OPPOSE SB
NINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. GIVE IT
JUST A MINUTE HERE WE DO HAVE
SOMEBODY IN Q. YOU CAN OPEN LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
REITER. AND THEN FURTHER HERE AT
THIS TIME I APOLOGIZE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY OPPOSED TO NINE FIFTY
FIVE HE NINE THIRTY FOUR BY
RUBIO NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
NINE THIRTY FOUR. HE LIKED A
POST PLEASE PRESS ONE HERE AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NOBODY INTO
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE THIRTY FOUR OVER THE FENCE
MOVING ON SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
BY SENATOR RUBIO ON. LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND
CLASS SIZE REDUCTION THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODDERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. TO SUPPORT
SB FORTY THIRTY ONE THREE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. EARLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. A POST SB
FORTY THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT ONE DIRECTED BY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. VOTER
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SB NINE
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR. ON
MEDICATION AND PATIENT SAFETY
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY EIGHT.
SO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOW WHAT A
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS A NEED LONGER BEHALF THE
CAL. HOUSEHOLDS AND SUPPORT. AND
CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FIFTY EIGHT THERE'S
SOMEBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE
FIFTY EIGHT. WELL OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF NINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOU KNOW QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FIFTY EIGHT WE
GOT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON S. THREE
TEN FORTY SEVEN ALSO BY SENATOR
RAMON AND EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TEN FORTY SEVEN. THIS PART SB
CAN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT A LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PAMELA GETS RATHER THAN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. NOW THAT OPPOSITION OF
TEN FORTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO TEN FORTY SEVEN. ANY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO IF
YOU'RE A LINE THIRTY IS WHEN.
LINE THIRTY YEAR OPEN. IN IN
FURTHERANCE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN IN OPPOSITION OF TEN FORTY
SEVEN SINA FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT SB TEN FORTY SEVEN GO TO
SUSPEND LIVING ON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LIMÓN
ON. APPOINT IT'S ASSIST FOR
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. SUPPORT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEIR OWN. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE
HEARING ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. CAPOS PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO SENATOR
LAYERS TO BILLS SB NINE SIXTY
THREE HONEST PRESERVATION THE
AUTHORS. WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF SUPPORTERS
NOBODY IN ROUTE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF NOT
SIXTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY NONE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF NINE
SIXTY THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED HEARING
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
OPPOSE SB. NINE SIXTY THREE. THE
POINT NINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY IN
Q. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO MORE
TESTIMONY AND NO COMMENT FROM MY
COLLEAGUE WE WILL PRESERVE THE
CULTURAL HISTORY AND PUT IT ON
SUSPENSE SB NINE SIXTY THREE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL BE ON S. B. NINE
SEVEN SEVEN BY SENATOR LAYERED
ON GRAZING LAND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NO ONE
RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE IT
WILL GO OUT OF THE PHONE LINE SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN. SUPPORT. FOR
NINE SEVEN SEVEN. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE ITS
BOARD OF NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
CURRENTLY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO THE OPPOSITE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO NINE
SEVEN SEVEN MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN. PRESS ONE ZERO
SO. HE CURRENTLY MANAGES ALL
RIGHT WE'VETAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN VOTER SUSPENSE
MOVING ONTO SENATOR HERTZBERG
HAS FIVE BILLS FIRST ONE IS NINE
SIX SEVEN ON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MATTERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES OPPOSED. TO NINE SIX
SEVEN. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS FINE. AND CURRENTLY
MANAGES OUR RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUPPORT FOR ME OPPOSITE IN NINE
SIX. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
LOTTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO NINE SIXTY
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME SO. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE SIXTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON SB NINE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ON STATE
SUPPLEMENTARY PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
TESTIFYING SUPPORT MODERATESOR
ANY SUPPORT TESTIMONY ON THE
PHONE LINE. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTOR THANK. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OPPOSED
TO NINE SEVENTY THREE MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB NINE SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO SO. AND THEN Q.
CURRENTLY. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB TEN
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
ENHANCE CLINICAL INTEGRATED
PROGRAMS FOR FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. TEN FOURTEEN.
PRESS ONE ZERO SO. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FOURTEEN IS
THERE ANYONE OPPOSED SB TEN
FOURTEEN IN THIS ROOM KNOW
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB TEN FOURTEEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE. CERTAINLY LEARNING QUEUE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN FOURTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB ELEVEN NINETY BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. ON DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIA TRUST
FRAMEWORK THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN NINETY. THE SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. EARLY NINETY. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO DROPPED OF ELEVEN
NINETY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
NINETY. YES ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
NOBODY AND YOU ALL RIGHT SEEING
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
AND HAVING TAKEN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN NINETY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ON LOCAL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
THIS ROOM. IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE ON
MOCKINGBIRD LANE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. AND SO WE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BECAUSE THE. NINETY THANK YOU AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT WILL GO TO OPPOSITION IS
ANYONE OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM ANYBODY THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE RURAL. THANK
YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WE SEE NO
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THIRTEENTH WITHOUT SUSPENSE
MOVING ON S. B. NINE NINE SIX BY
SENATOR KAMLAGER CAL WORK
SELLING TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WITH THE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE NINE SIX MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE SIX.
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION FOR NINE NINE
SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO NINE
NINE SIX. YES ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF NINE
NINE SIX THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE NINE SIX FOR
THE SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE S. B.
TEN FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR COM
LONGER ON TRIALS ENFORCEMENT
LICENSE SUSPENSION IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY
COMING IN THE MICROPHONE TO
SUPPORT SB TEN FIFTY FIVE. SO
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF TEN FIFTY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SOME. AND CURRENTLY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TEN FIFTY FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB.
TEN FIFTY FIVE. THE POST. ONE
CURRENTLY NINETY ALL RIGHT HAVE
TAKEN IN OPPOSITION OF TENTH
FIVE AND SEEING QUESTIONS WITH
OF. THANKS FOR FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO SENATOR
BRADFORD BILLS HE HAS SB TEN
TWENTY ONE AM VEHICLES DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL
OR DRUGS IT IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO TWENTY ONE. SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ARE I
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSES ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. TEN TWENTY ONE.
PRESS ONE SO. AND MANAGE AT THE
TIME ALL RIGHT WE TAKE SUPPORT
OF TEN TWENTY ONE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN TWENTY
ONE GO TO SUSPENSE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO SB ELEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
BY SEN BRADFORD ON CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE- IT'S AN URGENCY BUILD
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THERE'S
NO- OPTION ME IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN FOR
EIGHT. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT-
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THE
L. ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT. IF
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
CURRENTLY. NINETY TWO. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT WILL GO SUPPORT FOR.
SB FOUR SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR IS
ON PROCESS TAX IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND HE IS WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO WE WILL GO RIGHT
TESTIMONY SUPPORT PRESS BE
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AND SUPPORT MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IT'S
OF SB. FOURTEEN TWO. I APART
PLEASE PRESS ONE. CURRENTLY
NINETY THREE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
SUPPORT GO TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
SIXTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
SB FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. THANK
YOU CURRENTLY. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO IS THAT NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES OUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR CHAU BUG SHE HAS S. B.
THIRTY ONE ON HEALING ARTS. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENT SO WILL OPEN
THE HERE IN TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATES OR
ANYONE THE PHONE LINE AND OF SB. TEN ONE. IT'S SUPPORTED YOU
CAN THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE KIDS ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO DOWN THERE'S NOBODY
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OPPOSED TO
TEN THIRTY ONE MODERATE FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TEN THIRTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE SB. TEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. FIFTY
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN THIRTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON S. ELEVEN
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR RETRO VOTES
ON SPECIAL. THIS IS CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENT. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IT IN SUPPORT OF
SB. ELEVEN THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN THIRTEEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSING ELEVEN THIRTEEN
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO POLLS. THANK YOU WE'VE TAKEN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN THIRTEEN
AND THERE'S NOBODY WITH
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN THIRTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LIVING ON SB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE BY A CHAU ABOVE AND
PRIVATE RECREATION PROGRAMS-
THIS IS THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE COMING IN
THE MICROPHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE. WILL GO RIGHT TO THE PHONE
LINE IS OR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE. YOUR SUPPORT SB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN NINETY PRESS ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM COMING IN THE
MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE TWELVE ANY
NINE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE. YES ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NOBODY AND CUTE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT BY A CHOI
BOGUE ON BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WITHOUT-
FURTHER ADO WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF.
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTION SUPPORT SB
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE NINETY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED YOUR OPPOSING
IT IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB TWELVE NINETY
EIGHT. SO PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY NOBODY OPPOSING
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE NINETY
EIGHT AND SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS THE TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE UNDER PRO TEM ATKINS HAS
TWO BILLS SB TEN THIRTY FOUR ON
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS IS
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE PRO
TEM'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IT'S OF S. B. TEN
THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ELECTED FOR A FOURTH.
CURRENTLY NINETY CUTE ALL RIGHT
WE GOT OPPOSITION OF TEN THIRTY
FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB TEN
THIRTY FOUR. AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO TWO OPPOSE. CURRENTLY MANY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN THIRTY
FOUR AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN THIRTY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUS. MOVING ON TO SB
THREE SEVENTY POINT PROGRAMMATIC
IN ON NURSE AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE. SO
OPEN UP WE DO HAVE A PRIMARY
LEAD OPPOSING WITNESS BUT
THERE'S NO LEAD TO SUPPORT SO
WE'RE GONNA THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND SO YOUR LINE
SHOULD BE OPEN IF YOU TELL THEM.
IT DOESN'T CARE SO. ALL RIGHT SO
NOW WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION- I
IN MY NOTES THAT WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITE SUSAN AREN'T ALL. HE
MAY NOT BE ON THE COASTLINE IS
SHE ON THE GENERAL LINE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD FIND
SUSAN ON ALL YES I AM SHE- A
CLASS I AM ON THE LINE ALL RIGHT
I BELIEVE YOU'RE THE ONLY
PRIMARY WITNESS SO YOU HAVE.
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SUSAN ON ALL I AM AN ATTORNEY
AND I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT. OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS FOR THE RIGHT TO
LIFE LEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST PRO
LIFE ORGANIZATION. WHAT ARE THE
RISKS WOMEN FACE DURING AN
ABORTION. ACCORDING TO THE UK
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE THE
TOTAL ABORTION RELATED
COMPLICATION RATE IS ABOUT 2%
WHICH CHEMICAL ABORTIONS BEFORE
FOURTEEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY
ABOUT SEVENTY OUT OF ONE
THOUSAND WOMEN SUFFER
COMPLICATIONS REQUIRING SURGERY
. AFTER FOURTEEN WEEKS THREE OUT
OF A HUNDRED WOMEN SUFFER
COMPLICATIONS THAT REQUIRE
ANOTHER PROCEDURE. ONE OUT OF
EVERY ONE HUNDRED WOMEN WILL
SUFFER VERY HEAVY BLEEDING
REQUIRING SURGERY TO STOP AT.
THIS IS WHY DR OVERSIGHT AND
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES ARE
CRITICAL THEY ARE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT WOMEN FROM THESE RISKS.
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL
REMOVE BOTH DOCTOR OVERSIGHT OF
ABORTION AS WELL AS STANDARDIZED
PROCEDURES GOVERNING ABORTION.
WHY IS THAT A GOOD THING. LET'S
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL WHO
BENEFIT FROM REMOVING
STANDARDIZED MEDICAL PROCEDURES
- BENEFITS BY HAVING LESSER
SKILLED INDIVIDUALS PERFORMING
ABORTIONS WITHOUT DOCTOR
OVERSIGHT. WOMEN SEEKING
ABORTION NO THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY DOES SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IF A COST SAVING
DEVICE TO EXPAND WHO CAN DO
ABORTIONS AT A CHEAPER COST. THE
ABORTION INDUSTRY WILL NO LONGER
NEED TO PAY THE DOCTOR FOR HIS
OR HER TIME FOR FOLLOW
PROCEDURES SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE MEANS LET SKILLED
ABORTIONIST. AND CUT CORN AND
CUT CALL. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
WOMEN'S HEALTH AND EVERYTHING TO
DO WITH INCREASED PROFIT FOR THE
ABORTION. SO DON'T ANYONE OF YOU
ON THIS COMMITTEE DARESAY IS THE
SAN WOMEN'S HEALTH IT IS ABOUT
MAXIMIZING ABORTION PROFIT IT'S
BLOOD MONEY PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY AND I YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ALL RIGHT MODERATE
HELLO BACK TO THIS ROOM NO ONE
ELSE IN OF THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
IN THIS ROOM MONTEREY OR ANYONE
OF TO ANYONE THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THE FULL PLEASE ONE AT THE
TIME AND FOR THE OPPOSITION WERE
IN THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. AND WE CAN GO FIRST TO
LINE. THIRTY NINE. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE INGRAHAM WITHSTAND
THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE OPPOSE
. AND NEXT WEEK GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO. HI YEAH THIS MAY
HAVE A HOPELESS ENOUGH COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THANKS
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY. EVERY
TIME YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY
BE NEEDED. THE LINE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY MILES OPEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS YOUR PRIMARY
AND I. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE SINGLE
QUESTIONS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE ON THE SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB TEN FIFTY BY SENATOR JOHN ON
STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN TOLL
BRIDGE ACT THIS IS A SUSPENSE.
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO TEST MONEY
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN SUPPORT OF
TEN FIFTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE. LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FIFTY. PLEASE PRESS
DIRECTOR TIME INFO. SELECT
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO A OPPOSITION OF TEN
FIFTY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS RUNNING ON
THE PHONE LINE IS TO FIFTY. THE
POLL PLEASE PRESSED ZERO. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTY
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN FIFTY WITHOUT
ASSIST LIVING ON SB OF BY
SENATOR DODD ON VEHICLE
INSURANCE THIS IS CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESS WILL OPEN UP
THE HEARING IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED NOBODY HERE MATER ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. PRESS ONE ZERO
WITH SOME. THANK YOU CURRENTLY.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
OF S. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN MODERN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED MODERATE OR ANYONE
OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN OH SEVEN. YOU
WANT TO PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT HERE- LINE ONE.
HUNDRED DOLLAR AND HAPPEN
INSURANCE CAN RICARDO LARA AND
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE IN SUPPORT
. OR MAPS. THE INDOCTRINATING
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN OH SEVEN AND SEEING
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN
OH SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR MCGUIRE S.
B. TEN OR SHOULD BE MADE LEADER
MCGUIRE SPK SIXTY TWO ON THE
FIXING THE FIREFIGHTER SHORE IT
IS THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MISTER
REQUIRES WAY PRESENTATION WITH A
RITE PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. TEN SIXTY TWO. THE PART YOU
CAN SEE TWO PLEASE ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO APPOSITION OF S. B. TEN
SIXTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TEN
SIXTY TWO. INTRACOASTAL PRESS
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU CURRENTLY WE
DO HAVE ONE GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT HERE. THE TICKET TO COME
HOW. ALL RIGHT WE'VE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF TEN SIXTY TWO
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN SIXTY TWO WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON S. B.
ELEVEN FIVE. DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION INTERMODAL
PASSENGER SERVICES RAIL
CORRIDORS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
COMMON ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
ONE THERE WHICH IF. ELEVEN TEN
FIVE. REALLY NINETY K. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF LEVIN SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE GO TO SUSPENSE SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE PROHIBITED INVESTMENTS
AND CONTRACTS WITH RUSSIA AND
BELARUS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT. IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MIKE MADIGAN
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL CAN
SUPPORT A Q. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM AND SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. PRESS.
ONE FOUR. CURRENTLY NINETY YOU
ALL RIGHT WE WILL OPPOSITE AT
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT. YEAH ONE ZERO.
NOBODY ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION- WITHOUT
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
IN WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB THIRTEEN NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE ON FISH AND
WILDLIFE STEELHEAD TROUT THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
THE PUBLIC COMMON IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
MODDERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO COULD LIKE TO SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY NONE IF YOU ARE RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY TWO. AND PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NINETY OVERTOPPED OF THE NINETY
TWO THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TO TWO
HUNDRED MINERS DURING OPPOSE. TO
THIRTEEN NINETY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. SEEING NO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO A SUSPENSE HONESTY
THIRTEEN MAJORITY LEADER MCGUIRE
AND FOOD THIS FOR. IT IS
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED JUST HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO SO. IN NINETEEN TO AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE GOT
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN. POLITICS. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTION SO THAT OBJECTION IS
BEFORE THIRTEEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO THE BATTLE
OF HASTINGS S. B. TEN SIXTY SIX
BY CENTER HER TADO. FARMWORKER
DROUGHT RESILIENCY PILOT PROJECT
IT IS THIS CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WILL OPEN
UP PUBLIC COMMON ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LNE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SIXTY SIX. THANK TO SUPPORT EACH
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
THE OPPOSITION OR ANYONE OPPOSED
TO SB TEN SIXTY SIX THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO S.
B. TEN SIXTY SIX. AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED. AND
GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE. WE CAN
OPEN TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURKE CODY BOILED ME HALF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THAT WAS
OPPOSITION NO SUPPORT RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP FOR
OPPOSITION OF TEN SIX I THOUGHT
THAT WAS BOTH. HI MY JUST GIVE A
LAST OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. TO TEN
SIXTY SIX. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. EARLY MANY Q.
ARE I HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND HAVEN'T BEEN
RIGHT. WITHOUT OBJECTION AND NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN SIXTY SIX WILL GO INTO THE
HISTORY BOOKS AND ON SUSPENSE.
WE GO TO S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR
GONZALEZ I'M GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAIVED
PRESENTATION AND WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR. THESE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WITH IRAQ OF ELEVEN OH
FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATES OR ANYONE OPPOSED. TO
ELEVEN OH FOUR. THE POST PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NINETY. ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKE
SUPPORT NAPA ENCINO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION B. ELEVEN OH FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ ON STATE AND LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION ALONG UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON PHONE AND OF SPLM TO
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. MANY KIDS ALL RIGHT
WITH OPPOSITION OF LOVE TWENTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE BATTERIES OR ANYONE
OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN TWENTY ONE.
TO POST ELEVEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ONTO S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. ON
PUBLIC RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOSSIL
FUELS THIS IS A- SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. TO SUPPORT ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN. ZERO ME A MOMENT HERE-
TILL. FORTY ONE. JEFF FRIDAY'S A
FUTURE OR COUNTY SPEAKING
SUPPORT OKAY HALF THIRTY COUNTRY
. UNDER SENATOR BATES YEAH A
SENATOR BATES WITH INTO THE
NIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT WE CAN GO
TO LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. LARA REALLY. I SUPPORT SB ONE
ONE SEVEN TWO. THE DALLAS THAT
EXPENSE KIDNEY FAILURE TO HER
SANDY LIKE TO KILEY THANK YOU.
MIX OF A LINE. FORTY SEVEN. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY
I'M READY I'M FROM OUR PARKING I
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN THREE. AND I
AM A CHARACTER MEMBERS THANK YOU
. LINE ONE IF I HAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA SIMPSON I'M WITH
THE OF THREE FIFTY HUMBOLDT WE
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
AND WE THANK YOU THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE INTRODUCTION OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU
I AM ALSO A CALPERS MMBER THANK
YOU NEXT PERSON. LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS CLEAR BROWN UC BERKELEY
PROFESSOR ECONOMIC BASED ON MY
RESEARCH ON DIVESTMENT ICE
SUPPORT SB SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. AMEX'S LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAKE TAPPER OF
THE POWER CALLING IT A STRONG
AND I SEE ALLEGEDLY. AND
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MIKE MONAHAN BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE ASSURING ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSE TO LET SEVENTY
THREE. BUT POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. EMAIL MOMENT HERE. AGAIN
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND MINGLE
CRYSTALLINE. TWO THANK YOU YOUR
LINES OPEN. THE SCRIPT LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FOUR MARCH WAIT CAL STATE
RETIREMENT FOR ADOPTED. TO
ELEVEN THREE. CONNECT LINE FORTY
NINE. MISTER CHAIR AND PAUL DEAR
- REPRESENT WESTERN STATES
PROGRAMS SHE OPPOSITION TO U. S.
B. ELEVEN WITH THANK YOU. THE
BACULA TO TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GUARANTEED FOR
WOULD BECOME. BY MISTER ASSOC
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A LINE TWO. HI YES- ON
MANHOLE AND AT PUBLIC SB. ELEVEN
THREE. CURRENTLY NINE FURTHER IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN FOR
OPPOSITE OF SB ELEVEN SO THREE
NO FROM LIKE WITH OF. SB LEVIN
SEVENTY WILL GO SYSTEM. MOVING
ON SB TWO SIXTY BY SENATOR GUNS
ON THE SECRETARY OF THE
SECRETARY OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TEST IF SUPPORTERS ROOM
TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB TWELVE SIXTEEN. HE JUST APART
TWELVE SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO. WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION HAVE SB TWELVE
SIXTEEN THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TWELVE SIXTEEN. IMPOSED SB
TWELVE SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETEENTH ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE SIXTEEN
THREE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE SIXTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE ALSO BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ ON THE OFFICE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE EQUITY ADVOCATE
THIS IS THE SUSPENSE KENNEDY
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO SL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
FIFTY ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM KNOW MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO. TWELVE FIFTY ONE. ONE ZERO
TWELVE POSTS TWELVE. ONE NOBODY
IN Q. PROTECTIONS FOR IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON NEW SB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR BACKER STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER THIS IS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
NINE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSE MODERATES OR ANYONE
OPPOSED TO ELEVEN SEVENTEEN ON
THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TWELVE POLLS. AND CURRENTLY
MANY Q. AND THAT WAS SB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR BACKER ON
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WE'VE TAKEN TESTIMONY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
WILL GO TO SYSTEM MOVING ON SB
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN SENATOR PACKER
AND CAL POLICE OWNERSHIP
PROGRAMS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE HEARING ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTINOS.
PART S. B. SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SOME WILL OPEN
UP THE OPPOSITION THERE'S OBODY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATES FOR ANYONE OPPOSED. TO
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN. AND TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
CURRENTLY MANAGES ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FORTINO SEVEN WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN-
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TEST BE FOURTEEN NINETEEN
ALSO BY SENATOR PACKER ON HEALTH
INFORMATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMON ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE.
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOURTEEN
NINETEEN BY SENATOR BACKER.
INTERESTED PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETY. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
TO FOURTEEN NINETEEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM- MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO FOURTEEN NINETEEN. INTERPOSED
PLEASE. ONE ZERO. YEAH WE HEAR
FOR A LINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I NATALIE HOAGLAND
CENTER DINO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
AS BEFORE. NINE YEAH THAT'S ONE
ZERO TWO OPPOSE. AND KNOWN FOR
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WELL TO MIKE
THERE'S NO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOURTEEN NINETEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL BE ON THE SENATE
BACKERS FORTY EIGHTY ONE ON
PRESCHOOL CHILD DAYCARE
FACILITIES IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL O TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY MANICURE THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION FOR FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATION ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE. QUESTION
YOU HAVE. THE POST PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND CURRENTLY MANY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
WILL GO TO. MOVIE HONEST HAMBURG
ELEVEN ON PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFERS IS
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THERE'S
NO COMING IN THE MICROPHONE
WORLD UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FORTY
MODERATION ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTOR
SUPPORT. I AM CURRENTLY LEARNING
QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVED
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
ELEVEN FORTY. TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FORTY AND
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ONE FORTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
UNIT FOR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
BUSINESSES CANDIDATE THE AUTHOR
HAS WAY FOR PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE SUPPORT
QUALITY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU OUR RIGHTS WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
ONE LEAD APART OPPOSITION WISHED
WITNESS. CHRISTIAN WHITTEN IS
SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE LINE. OUR
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YOU KNOW YOU'RE THIS IS YOUR
FIRST WHAT THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SIR WELL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS CHRIS
WHITTEN MAY NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE GRADUATE. OF HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW AND THEY
RETIRED- A CALIFORNIA DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL. OF CHIEF.
OFFICER FOR HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW REPORTED RECENTLY THE
NEW YORK TIMES THAT THE COST OF
CHANGING THE NAME JUST FOR
BUILDING SIGNAGE EMAIL AND OTHER
MATTERS LIKE THAT. A COULD BE IN
EXCESS OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS
MONEY THAT COULD BE BETTER SPENT
ON THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS BEING PROPOSED AND
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE NATIVE.
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA ALSO.
THE AGREEMENT THAT SERENITY
ENTERED INTO WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- BACK IN THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS IN EXCHANGE FOR HIS ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
IS ABOUT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TODAY. IS THAT THE NAME OF THE
COLLEGE QUOTE SHALL FOREVER BE
KNOWN AND- AS BASTING COLLEGE
THE LAW THAT IN EDUCATION CODE.
NINE TWO TWO ZERO ZERO- THAT-
GREEN AT STIPULATED THAT IF THE
COLLEGE QUOTE CEASES TO EXIST
UNQUOTE. THE STATE OWES HASTINGS
AIRS. THE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PLUS ANY ACCRUED
INTEREST FROM THAT TIME. THAT'S
IN EDUCATION CODE NINE TWO TWO
ONE TWO- BY NAMING THE COLLEGE
SOME OTHER THAN HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF THE LAW. THE LAW CALLER
CERAMIST BARGAIN FOR WILL CEASE
TO EXIST AND THE STATE WILL OWE
THAT MONEY TO HIS HEIRS. OKAY
AND THE MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I MAY
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
SUCH A WONDERFUL LIGHT HEARTED
DEMONSTRATION PATIENCE AND
TOLERANCE IS WARNING. THANK YOU
SIR I'LL TAKE THAT. ALL RIGHT
THAT IS OUR LEAD WITNESS WILL
COME BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR OTHER
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE. WHO IS
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND
ENJOY MY LIGHT HEARTED BANTER.
BEGIN PRESS WONDER AT THE TIME
SO. CURRENTLY NONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR MAN
ON TRANSIT OPERATORS STREET
HARASSMENT THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS IT LIGHT
HEARTED. AWESTRUCK MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS KALEY I BEHALF OF
THE LAW ANGELES COUNTY.
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY A PROUD
COAST. WE WOULD URGE YOUR I
VOTED THE APPROPRIATE TIME
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANY OTHER
SUPPORT FOR ELEVEN SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR MEN ON THE PHONE LINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FOR SINGLE LINE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE
OURS ON TO OF CHINESE FOR FROM
ACTION AND. FOR JUST A MOMENT
HERE FOR ONE MORE YEAR TO ME
JUST A MINUTE.
HELLO LINE IF. SIX I MY NAME. GO
AHEAD WHEN. HI THIS IS THE POWER
OF THE CAN COMMISSION ON ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN.
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NONE Q.
ALL RIGHT WHAT BACK OPPOSITE
ROOM TO TWO HIGH THERE'S NOBODY
HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE ON PHONE
UP TO SIX ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TWO OPPOSE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE SUPPORT UP OF TO ONE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON SPLM SIX FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN ON ENERGY BUILDING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE CENTER STERN'S WAY
PRESS- PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT
SPLA. SIXTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS.
ONE TO FIFTY. EARLY MANY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO AROUND OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR.
INTERPOSE PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. CURRENTLY MEDICARE ARE
WE'VE TAKEN OPPOSITION AND WE
HAVE NO QUESTION SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
WITHOUT A FENCE IN ONE THE NEXT
BILL BY SENATOR STERN SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE ON COASTAL
RESOURCE. IT IS THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES INTO OF. FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. AND IF SO PLEASE ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. IN THE FIRST EIGHT
HE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR IT'S
MARCH HIM WITH A COUPLE LAND
ACTS NETWORK- DOESN'T OF GROUPS
OPENED THE- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TO ALLOW FIFTY FOUR FIFTY AHEAD
. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE-
OKAY. AND I FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS MEREDITH TROUT ONE I
LIVE IN VENICE CALIFORNIA I'M
WITH PROTECT AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FURTHER Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE COME ON UP
. MISTER CHAIR A ALSO KNOWN AS
HE OF UNLIMITED PATIENCE. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR JUST TALK TO MY
FAMILY. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED TO S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE ON THE PHONE LINE.
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSE.
CURRENTLY NINE BUT WE DO HAVE
ONE HERE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT
TOTALING FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CAREY MEMBERS OF
THE YEAR ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN J. STROLLING ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. FURTHERING ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT NOW OF
S. B. TO THREE WE NO CALL QUITE
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE WE GOT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
STERN- PROPERTY TAXATION WELFARE
EXEMPTION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TWO SUPPORT. AND
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITE TO FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. AND IT
FEELS LIKE TO PULL PLEASE PRESS. ONE IN CURRENTLY NINETY. ALL
RIGHT WITH FOR NOT FOR FIFTY SIX
BY SENATOR STERN. AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION WITHOUT OF FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX REGARDLESS. MOVING ON
THE ELEVEN NINETY BY SENATOR CAO
GYRO ON WATER INNOVATE AND
DROUGHT WE- THIS IS THIS CAL THE
SENATOR AS WE PRESENT. WILL GO
TO PAY TESTIMONY IT'S THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TO TWO HUNDRED
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES INTO OF S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE'S- CURRENTLY NINETY. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO DROPPED THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
TO NINETY SEVEN MY OR ANY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSE TO A LOT
NINETY SEVEN. AND PLEASE PRESS
ZERO SO. AND THEN I YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN FOR OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
ELEVEN SEVEN GO TO. ME ON THIS
THIRTEEN EIGHT BY SENATOR CABDI.
I'M PUBLIC EDUCATION INSTITUTES
PURCHASE OF NON DOMESTIC I FOOD
PRODUCTS IT THIS CANDIDATE THE
AUTHOR WAVE PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN OH EIGHT.
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE BUSINESS.
THANK YOU ARE I WILL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN AWAY
. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE. IN ANY QUEUE ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN AWAIT
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE NSP
THIRTEENTH SIX I SENATOR ON
CANNOT INTERSTATE AGREEMENT. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED NOBODY
HERE MODERATORS FOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX. TRANSPORT
TWENTY SIX THE FRESH. ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WORK OFF AS
OF THE TO SIX NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
HUNDRED OPPOSE MODERATE HEARING
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE TO
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO S. AND YOU WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON S. B. TWELVE
NINETY SIX BY DR PAN ON VIRAL
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE GOOD
DOCTOR'S WAY PRESENTATION. SO WE
WILL OPEN UP. THAT IS A SUSPENSE
CANNOT WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE TO TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY
ANSWER. MODERATION ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX. IF SO PLEASE
PRAY ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINE YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO OPPOSITE IS NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OPPOSED TO
TWELVE NINETY SIX MODERATION
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB. TWELVE NINETY SIX. ME AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. WE GO TO THIRTY SIX WE'VE GO
AHEAD. MESSAGES ON THE MERITS
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I HAVE. FOR
CHOOSING OPPOSE. IF IN LAW NINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YES LARRY HOGAN FROM TURKEY
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE SB. NINETY
MEXICO LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M I'M BEHALF
CALIFORNIA PARENTS OF MINORS AND
CITIZENS. EIGHT TWELVE NINETY
SIX THANK YOU FOR. MEXICO LINE.
THIRTY NINE. GABRIELLE INGRAM
BAND THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE NINETY SIX
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE NINETY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE ALSO BY DR PAN ON
HOSPITALS THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE GOOD DOCTOR'S WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE O THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO OPPOSE. WHEN THE LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GABBRO INGRAM I ATTENDED. ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE. METROLINE.
THIRTY TWO. MALEY HOGAN AND I
OPPOSE. IN MEXICO LINE. FIFTY
AREA CODE ON BEHALF OF PARENTS
AND MINOR I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND NEXT IN THE LINE THIRTY SIX.
THE HEAD. THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS YOUR PRIMARY
EFFECT ON OUR COUNTY AND I.
INTERNALLY MAN FURTHERING Q. ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINETEEN OF QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR THE RAZA ON THE
ROSENTHAL FAIR DIALECT DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL
GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR. AND IF SO YOUR LINE SHOULD BE
OPEN. I ARCHITECTURE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION ABILITY YOU HAVE
ONE OKAY OTHER LINE. BUT JUST AS
QUICK IT IS ONE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT THAT THEY TAKE
THEMSELVES OUT. YEAH PLEASE COME
BACK IN LET'S TRY THIS AGAIN
HERE OVER LINE FIFTEEN THIS IS
SUPPORT. FOR THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS IF IT. IF IT'S OKAY I'D
LIKE TO READ QUICKLY THE LIST OF
SUPPORTERS- SURE IF THE- HE
QUICKLY LEFT ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY IN
HOT CALIFORNIANS FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
LENDING COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES
HELLO FELLOW LAWYERS TWENTY
FIRST RIGHT. OF THE AREA BUT I
THINK LEGAL SERVICES CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
ADVOCACY SERVICES NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER PUBLIC
PASSENGER PUBLIC COUNCIL CONTROL
THE GOLDEN LARA OVER ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY LEGAL AID OF MORAN
RIVERSIDE LEGAL AID AND WALKED
IN THE BILL LAWCENTER AN APOLOGY
DALY HELLO HI ON BEHALF OF THE.
POLLUTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND CURRENT NINE FURTHER IN ALL
RIGHT WELL NOW THAT OFFICE OF SP
THREE TO FOUR NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR. THE FRESH
ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. CURRENTLY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVE ON SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR DRAWS ON
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE IN
ROOM THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE.
MODERATOR SUPPORT THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE I APOLOGIZE MAYBE WAS ON
UNTIL SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IT CURRENTLY MANY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE. IN A POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
THANK. THANK YOU I WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR
BY SENATOR DRAWS ON THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA VENDORS IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION- SO
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBECTION S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO SB FORTINO SIX BY SENATOR
RAZA ON EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
BINDING ARBITRATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMON IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN OH SIX. SUPPORT
FORTINOS SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN GROW AT THIS TIME. YES. ONE ZERO. ONE OF THE MAIN
OPERATOR GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE.
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI SHEILA TOLD ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. YES.
ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK AGAIN ONE DIFFICULT
MOMENT OKAY. WHEN HERE.
GALLAGHER NUMBER HERE. THIS IS
MANAGERS YEAH ONE FINE LINE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ILLEGAL MOST HERO CLUB- ANGELA'S
CHARACTER IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE. OR NOT ON
THAT BILL BUT THANK YOU. I'M SO
SORRY ALL GOOD. AND THAT
CURRENTLY NINE FURTHER AND CUTE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTINO SIX WILL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB FORTINO SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO FORTINO SIX. THE POST FORTINO
SICK PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY MEDICAID ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB FORTINO SIX THERE'S NO
OBJECT NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FORTINO SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE BY SENATOR WELCOME
HOMELESS POPULATION CENSUS IS
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION SO-
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT MODERATES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE. THE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. CURRENTLY
NONE NICK YOU ARE AYE WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT WILL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PROPOSED.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE WAS ON
SPENCER SPEAK THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR BORDERS I
PERSONAL INCOME TAX DEDUCTIONS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SUPPORTERS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. MODERATES FOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO IT MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN ON PERSONAL
INCOME TAX DEDUCTIONS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION OR WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODDERS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. FOUR SB
THIRTY SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
AT THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED OPPOSED MODERATE HEARING
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. YES ONE
AND THEN ZERO OPPOSE. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN AND WITHOUT OBJECTION AND
NO COMMENTS SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN ALSO BY
SENATOR NEWMAN ON PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE COLLABORATIVE
COLLABORATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY RUSSIAN IN THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF.
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN. SUPPORT
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BAKER IN ANY QUEUE
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY RUSHING
IN THE MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
INFO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY VICE CHAIR BATES WHO WAS
IT'S ON CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VICE CHAIR HAS WAY PRESENTATION
IT IS A SUCCESS DISPENSED
CANDIDATES TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IS SUPPORTED SB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. PRESS ONE
TO RECORD SUPPORT SB. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT WILL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM KNOW ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSE
WITHIN ONE THEIR OWN. GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT HERE WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINETEEN. I HAVE A QUESTION
LAURA ROSENBERGER HIERATIC
QUESTIONABLE PARAMILITARY STUFF
ABOUT ABOUT ALL RIGHT MA'AM JUST
STATE YOUR POSITION PLEASE. I
DON'T KNOW. ALL RIGHT NEXT
PERSON THANK YOU HE RETIRED
MILITARY CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE THE- I AGREE WITH
THAT OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT SO
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPEND. MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL
BILL. SENATOR MELENDEZ ON SB
FOURTEEN ELEVEN PERSONAL INCOME
TAXES EXCLUSION UNIFORMS
SERVICES RETIREMENT PAY THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN ELEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. HI NOBODY IN CHARACTER
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN ELEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN ELEVEN ON THE PHONE
LINE. PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE.
I CURRENTLY NINETEENTH ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOURTEEN ELEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE- THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ITEMS TODAY- THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE- FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WE THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TEST FIRE FOR
SOME REASON- THE TELECONFERENCES
DIDN'T- DIDN'T ADMIT YOU WERE
SOMETHING. THAT WE DO WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU SO PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE INCLUDED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS SO
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND FOR EVERYONE
FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AS WE GET THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE. REMOTE PARTICIPATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AGENDA
FOR THE DAY AND THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.